everyone quit see here I think you all
can hear me I think we're we're starting
so first of all I want to welcome you to
free code camps May 20 27 this is a very
exciting event for us because we haven't
had one of these summits in like a year
and a half two years because we've been
so busy working on other things
but I am thrilled I'm over the moon to
announce a lot of the big things that
we've been doing today we are working in
public as you know on our open source
project but a lot of things that we're
trying to do we we try not to make too
big of a deal out of them because we
don't want a whole bunch of speculation
and a whole bunch of you know gossip
because it's much like the biggest
challenge in running a big distributed
organization like freako camp is
communicating things effectively so what
we are going to try to do during this
one ish our summit is communicate as
much as possible about what we're doing
and is candid away as we can we are not
gonna try to build up tons of hype this
is not gonna be like one of those Steve
Jobs types talks this is gonna be super
casual and I can see that we have a lot
of people in chat I can see that a lot
of you are probably joining maybe this
is the first livestream you've watched
here on YouTube we have tons of live
streams we we have Jesse Weigel who's in
the in the chat right now he streams a
lot after this summit we are going to
have a very special live stream from
Florin pop who's also in the chat if you
join and you want to become a supporter
you can talk to him in there they are
gonna be streaming or Florin is gonna be
streaming a whole lot of project boiler
problems which if you haven't heard of
project oil or it's this 20 issue year
old website that has a bunch of coding
challenges that tens of thousands of
people
solved and we've taken a lot of those
which are Creative Commons taking those
and we put them on freak opium when
we've added a bunch of tests to them and
created like a nice a better experience
the project overload net no no offense
to them they're they're great but it's
just kind of tedious to do the
challenges there so we made it easier to
do that so we have this new challenge
the project Euler 100 hashtag project
Euler 100 and it's solving the first 100
particular problems and floran pop is
diving in and attempting in we've had
dozens of people at this point who
started it I don't know of anybody who's
actually finished 100 yet but we just
started it a few months ago so people
are working toward that so be sure to
stick around for that I am very excited
I'm gonna just start by talking about
this YouTube channel that we're on we
have grown dramatically in the past in
the past two years really this YouTube
went from for the first four years of
freako camps life we were just
publishing as many little short
tutorials as we could on different
topics like big o-notation and get and
things like that and then we started to
publish these big long full courses and
at this point we have hundreds of full
length courses that were showing ad-free
because we don't run ads on this channel
i think we're one of the biggest
channels that doesn't run any ads at all
you can just find a full-length course
you can work through it almost all these
have like code samples and other things
so while you're here on the channel be
sure to subscribe
be sure to also consider supporting the
channel we have this new join button if
you click it you'll become a member and
you can do things like chat during our
live streams which we restricted live
stream chat because if we don't we just
get a whole bunch of you know hey how's
it going you know like really quick
casual messages so this makes it a lot
easier for us to moderate it otherwise
we streaming by like lightning speed so
be sure to join
all all proceeds above the 30% that
YouTube takes the the 70% goes to our
nonprofit and helps us operate and I'm
gonna be talking a whole lot about other
initiatives that we have going on today
too but I'm I'm gonna get out of the way
in just a minute for the main people are
gonna be talking and that is a b-bow and
Ragesh so all I want to say before I
hand it off from Ragesh is our community
is growing really fast we have a ton of
new people joining the community helping
one another learn to code it's fantastic
we now have a forum where you can ask
questions to get help we have a series
of discord discord chat rooms where you
can go to get motivation and hang out
with other people and just it you know
during this pandemic when we're not able
to talk face-to-face it's great to be
able to talk to people virtually and
freako camp has a giant community online
where you can do just that and and feel
some affinity for other developers and
get get picked back up when you feel
down so hang in there we also have our
subreddit if you haven't joined it yet
it's our freako camp thank you very much
to Arielle Leslie and her amazing
stewardship of that community and we
have a giant Facebook group if you're on
Facebook still in 2020
Joan it it's it's called freako Camp
Earth so if you just search freako camp
Earth you'll find it and a lot of really
helpful people over there as well at
this point I'd like to also mention that
we do have merchandise I don't see it
showing up underneath this video but
when you're watching youtube videos on
freako camp you will see videos that
like this shirt for example this is
actually three years old I've washed it
more than 150 times I know because I
wear it every week and it's been about
three years since I bought it
so even after three years you can see
the lettering is it still fits great
you can see like the elasticity the
bands are great that's because it's a
tribal in shirt it's polyester rayon and
cotton and it's like it's just a really
really nice shirt it like hugs my body
really well and it doesn't stretch out
and it's super comfortable so we if you
do look and get a chance to buy like a
shirt or a hoodie or a mug or a cap
we're shooting for like the highest
quality that teespring this company that
does the production and fulfillment
we're using the highest quality versions
of all the products that they have so
the prices are a little bit higher but
it's worth paying an extra five bucks to
get a shirt that lasts for you know 150
washes instead of disintegrating after
50 that's my philosophy so you can
support us that way you can support us
by joining the chat you can support us
by doing a super chat which I see some
people are doing thank you for doing
that by the way and you know together
we're gonna keep this organization going
keep it growing and keep producing
awesome courses now I would like to hand
it over to Mukesh Mukesh is going to
demonstrate the new contributor site and
talk a little bit more about our
infrastructural challenges as we grow
dramatically Mukesh is a seasoned
developer I think he's the only person
on the free cooking up team who actually
has a computer science degree but he he
is from bangaluru
or Bangalore as it was called recently
and he is just an amazing developer he
is the main person whom we all call if
we have some sort of dramatic outage or
we have a major infrastructural decision
Rakesh thanks Quincy for that
introduction and yeah so welcome
everyone to a summit of record camp we
really hope to do this you know like
more often like concei already said and
yeah if something breaks on free code
camp probably I am the person to blame
but anyways let's let's
talk about you know some of our growth
reefs in these recent times as you we we
are about 400 we have about four million
registered users on our learning
platform which is the coding platform
that you go to and you know learn to
code and on various certifications we
have about 400 18k users on our forum
and just to show you some stats here's
our Alexa rank we are doing about 1100
you know globally and we have gained
about 633 ranks in the last 90 days
alone
and to show you something even more fun
in the past 24 hours we have had about
400 K unique visitors on the on across
all of you know free code cam and at the
minute we have at least 4,000
concurrent's you know across various
platforms for those many people are you
know like actually they're on free code
can actually it's even more than that
because we don't register all the server
side requests and you could be working
on your own but yeah that gives you a
quick idea of you know like how
code Jam is then you're going to say
that hemogauge there are all this big
numbers and what do we make of it the
thing is these dramatic growth that we
have had in you know like these
obviously trying times is because of you
know like people seeking more
opportunities to learn to learn to call
when they are at home and just seeking
resources to be able to skill them up
when this these lockdowns get over to
find jobs or you know do something with
whatever skills they have fun build a
project you know start a startup the
thing is even the free code camp
operates at such huge scales it does not
have as much operating budget our total
operating budget is one two hundredth of
Wikipedia
and that's less than some of the
salaries of some of the developers in
the Bay Area you know and that's that
includes everything it includes the
payroll for the staff it includes
servers it includes everything you know
that's the entirety of record care so
every time when Quincy asked me that hey
our forums getting slower you know the
new site is getting slow and just spin
up another server in the back of my mind
I have the thing that here we are four
million users we have five thousand
people donating to us if I spin one more
server I'm probably going to cost 16
developer 16 you know people who are
contributing one more you know one more
month's worth of you know donations so
it's it's a cat-and-mouse game you know
like all these big companies they have
this huge huge infrastructure where they
Auto scale they have you know blue green
deployments and rollbacks and fancy
pipelines and all that we could do that
it's not it's not about the you know the
ability it's more about you know the
constraints that we are operating at so
I just want to give you a quick you know
like you know mock-up that I have built
up of our of our network chat this is
this is not close to you know whatever
we have in reality but it's it's an
approximation so we have you know all
these different apps they learn / news /
forum you know like people visiting us
from all across the world we have
CloudFlare as our CDN and our DNS
provider so you know we are managing all
our traffic through CloudFlare at the
minute we use odd zero to authenticate
and then to give you you know how nimble
and tiny our stack is you just have a
couple of engineer Kansas instances
which are load-balanced these are there
are a couple handful of you know API
instances a couple instances for our you
know front-end static sites and one
instance because it's monolithic for
Ghost which is you know like serving our
news app and of course we have our
database instances and this is the all
of free code campaign you know that's
that's that's how small of a stack this
is
do want to scale this up rapidly and
doing so is quite easy now that we have
improved upon the scaling in the recent
times what we can do is for instance if
if you know like we see the concurrence
getting bumped up on our nginx instances
we can just spin one more add it to the
pool and the load balancer will take
care of you know like serving the
traffic so what this means
oh yeah we also have a forum instance
which is probably you know one of the
most visited platforms on forum weeks at
any given point of time we have about
600 to 800 people there and it's you
know thankfully sponsored by discourse
huge shout out to them Jeff amazing guy
and the these things these things you
know the architecture or you know they
these things take a lot of our time when
we are trying to develop features we do
not want to be maintaining stack we want
to be building features for you and you
can help us by obviously donating and
you know helping us scale up to a place
where you know we don't have to worry
about you know like getting spikes and
you know spending sleepless nights to
you know spin one more server just to
have all the resources available to you
that said let's jump to the other part
which is contributing to the code Jam
all this is good you can donate to free
code camp but there are other ways if
you cannot donate you can camp in
various different ways and I am really
happy to announce that we have this
brand-new contributing site you just go
to contribute dots we call ChemDraw todd
will tweet it out and you can even check
it in our you know the article that
quincy published even in the description
the link will be available there but
it's just contribute dots we call cam
door talk and that's going to be your
central place where you can go to you
know help us in tiny ways for example
you can help people by answering their
coding questions on our community forum
you can give them feedback on their
projects you can add subtitles to
youtube channel videos you know we we
want our youtube channel videos not just
to be available in English but various
world languages and of course last but
not the least you
can contribute to code base and this
guide it's it has everything that you
are probably going to need to be able to
contribute to the code base you can you
know work on coding challenges you can
work help with help us with adding you
know subtitles you can help us with
adding multiple choice questions to our
video challenges which Bo will talk
about in a minute
you can set up record camp locally if
you wanted to work on you know like the
platform side of things you can learn
about how we deploy three code camp you
know like it's uh everything is deployed
from you know like pipelines we have
built we had CI CD integration of course
and you can read all about this you know
like on this guide we even have some
flight manuals for our staff and mod -
you know like help them do their
day-to-day jobs like moderating you know
the chat rooms and all that and most
importantly you can you should check the
links right here in our community these
are links to seek help about
contributing so you can hang out hang
out with us on our you know community
forum we have a dedicated contributors
category and we also have a dedicated
chat room where you can you know come
say hi and ask questions about
contributing you know just say what you
are doing these days and we'll love to
hang out with you so yeah that's that's
mostly how frequent camp operates it's
very tiny team but it's possible because
of thousands of kind volunteers like you
so come hang out with us yeah you want
to take it away Quincy yeah absolutely
and while we have your screen up here
just a real quick since you have those
tabs let's go ahead Joe let's show
everybody what the separate it looks
like real quick so this is of course the
free code camp subreddit we have tons of
people asking and answering questions
here so be sure to check this out if
you're on Reddit just join they
subreddit and I think you'll find it's
helpful and in case
the cool stuff will come up just in your
normal reddit feed if you're subscribed
to this subreddit next the freako Camp
Earth Facebook group there are a lot of
people in here this is a really cool
interface are you using the mobile
version of Facebook itself but they
updated it I think it's available to you
know like I don't know how its made
available but I think you know I'm
signed up on the lip thing I don't know
how I got this it looks very similar to
Twitter if you notice what there's a
trend toward going to like single column
layouts or trying to reduce the amount
of noise on the sides we'll get to that
in a minute when Abby talks but this
looks way better what Facebook currently
looks like this is cool anyway um free
code camp birth be sure to join that
group really wanted a shout-out to all
the moderators we have like this amazing
moderator team on Facebook so thank you
all for everything you're doing next of
course the free code camp form which
Ragesh mentioned earlier there are a lot
a refresh it because you refresh this
now this this is a pretty active forum
and you're gonna see that there are a
lot of people asking and answering
questions and even though it's a forum
and it feels a synchronous you can see
like just in the past 20 minutes we've
had like six or seven posts so it may
feel asynchronous because you're like
asking a question you have to wait to
get the answer but this is the best way
to get answers in my humble opinion
forms are way better than like chat or
social media or anything like that if
you if you can wait you know an hour
typically you'll get a response within
about an hour if you if you post a
question or if you want to get feedback
on your project so do be sure to create
a forum account currently you have to
kind of sign in separately with the
forum we're working on marrying those
two accounts and just getting everything
behind auth0
which is what we've been using for our
authentication on the on the the main
learned curriculum so and then last but
not least of course we recently launched
discord
which is a big chat server and there's
my announcement in there watching what
engi people we're gonna cheese waiting
but I think somebody needs to upload the
I one so that it is in front of the tea
I'm not sure whether it's in that
sequence but if you if you come in here
we've got a whole lot of chat room we
don't have a whole lot we try to keep
the conversation relatively constrained
so these can be like more productive and
we don't have a bunch of ghost town chat
rooms that nobody talks in if you join
any of these chat rooms over here you'll
you'll find that they've got their own
vibrant communities you'll also note for
later reference that there's a project
Euler 100 chatroom here there's also an
AWS certified chatroom these are two
different challenges we have going
within the free cocaine community so
these are places where you can share
your wins like if you get an AWS
certification you can talk about it here
Johan reen just got the hardest one I
think the developer associate won a
couple days ago so this is a really
great place also to just chat in real
time and many of us are working from
home or just hanging out of the house
because school's out for the most part
jump in and find your tribe right here
online we're gonna give you the tools
and a very friendly community there
around I think six thousand people or so
that have joined this to discord server
in the past three or four weeks since we
launched it and we have great moderators
everybody follows the code of conduct
people who don't get banned completely
candid like we're not shy about banding
people who don't buy the code of conduct
because we've found that for every toxic
person you know and non toxic people
will get scared away so we're very
aggressive about enforcing our code of
conduct and we really mean it when we
say that we're a super inclusive
community so next I would like to hand
it off to Abbie Abbie is a Portlander
she's from Portland which is an amazing
and interesting city up in the Pacific
Northwest in the United States and we
have a lot of contributors
from Portland and there are a lot of
really exciting open-source projects
coming out of there as well and of
course you know Washington and so it's
not just California on the west coast
we've got awesome cities like Portland
and Seattle as well so Abby is going to
talk about a number of things but the
big thing she's going to talk about is a
very invisible process that's been going
on that's going to make your life a lot
better that you don't even know about
yet so I'm gonna let have you talk about
that hey Abby hey thanks Quincy and
everybody it's really great to be here
with you all today thanks for joining
our livestream yeah I'm here in sunny
Portland today a nice change in the
weather oh yeah I didn't talk about this
sneaky project that Quincy mentioned so
some of you might be familiar with free
code camps guide so the guide is a
collection of a whole bunch of articles
that a bunch of really wonderful
contributors have put together over the
years and it's a great resource you know
if you google something oftentimes
you'll get a guide article but you know
it's not necessarily the easiest reading
experience so or the easiest user
experience and so we have been working
myself and one of our other team members
Chris have been working on transitioning
all the guide articles over to free code
camp news news is our main publication
that you also might be familiar with
which will look more at in a minute so
you can see the guide here you know it's
it's very functional
it just has tons of information but now
we are taking all these articles and we
are transferring them first we kind of
we go through we clean them up we're
making sure that all you know everything
has nice syntax highlighting in our news
interface and everything like that and
so we're basically cleaning these
articles up and putting them into news
so you'll have a better reading
experience a cleaner interface the news
has syntax highlighting it has all the
great features that you'd expect wanting
to just read a technical article so
Chris and I have been going through and
transferring these articles from the
guide over to news now there are
thousands of articles on the guide we've
been working on about the most
sort of read thousand or so and you can
see what an article looks like on news
now compared to guide it's nice and
clean it's easy to read and we've taken
some articles from the guide and
combined them if they're really short
little articles like this one on array
methods and JavaScript there were a
whole ton on the guide so we put them in
one article so that you have all these
array methods and all this information
about arrays all in one nice clean place
news also has amp accelerated mobile
pages so you'll have a much better
reading experience on your mobile phone
so I just want to emphasize again that
these articles are a product of
thousands of individual creators and
contributors so thank you for all those
contributions and now these articles are
just going to be easier to read and more
accessible and more helpful to more
people so this is not live quite yet I
just want to note it will be hopefully
in the next couple weeks we're just
finishing up a few details but in the
next couple weeks you'll have a whole
lot more articles on news to help you
with all these you know detailed
searches that you might be doing all
that will be available on news now so
that's a really exciting project and I
want to thank Chris couch Ogawa who's
probably watching this stream and he's
in South Korea is one of our team
members and he's just been instrumental
in making this happen so that's really
exciting for us so next I want to talk a
little bit about something else that
Chris is very involved and is searching
on on ghost on free code camp news that
we run on ghost so you might not realize
that you can search on free code camp
news so if Akash we should want to go to
one of those new articles that we talked
about we can kind of demo search and
then look at the articles themselves so
there's a search bar up in the upper
left corner of news and there are over
six thousand articles indexed on news we
use algo Lea and that also provides our
search bar super great service it's
really fast so you can see like right
when we got started typing results
instantly started appearing the results
are based on the headlines with articles
and they're sorted by relevancy so the
newest articles will be at the top and
if you want to see more results um you
can either just hit enter or you can
click on the little like see more
results down at the bottom and then
you'll get everything like for
Python you know they'll be probably
hundreds of articles the other great
thing about this search feature is that
if you like miss type something
accidentally like if murugesh was to
leave out the y and python or whatever
it'll still come up tada
with all the Python results so it's
really good about fixing like spelling
errors or typos and you'll still get
what you're looking for
so that's awesome and I just wanna give
a big shout out again to Chris he's the
one who manages search and indexes all
the articles he just does such a great
job making sure that there's everything
that you need in there so go forth and
search in freaky okay F news you'll find
a whole bunch of really great stuff so
the last thing I want to talk about is
just some of the articles that we've
been publishing lately on news news has
been growing we have a whole bunch of
authors that just published really
really good stuff and lately we've had
some really good in-depth articles and
this is sort of the direction that we're
going with news we'll continue to
publish all different kinds of content
and on all different kinds of topics but
you can see like with this first example
Phoebe wrote this article on computer
programming software development very
broad topic but it's an incredibly
in-depth article it might be like a
twenty or thirty minute read or
something like that but it really just
gives you a great foundation about
programming if you just need to kind of
learn the basics it's very well
organized so we're really encouraging
people to publish in-depth beginners
guides like that so people can really
get started and just learn the basics
another great example of an article what
do we have next let's look at TK's
article on so we publish a lot of these
really great in-depth technical guides
so TK's written this article about you
know building this great pokemon web app
so if you're a Pokemon fan it's great
check it out
but again he includes lots of images and
code snippets great step-by-step details
helpful headings so we have we publish a
lot of really great technical articles
like beautiful highlighting so that's
another type of article we really enjoy
publishing we also publish a lot of
basically like programming language
guides or intros to various programming
languages like we have an example from a
new author
on rainin I'm not trying to pronounce
his name that is about Python so this is
just a beginner's guide to Python so you
can just learn all kinds of the basics
of Python from this article and again
it's it's super long but it has a nice
table of contents at the beginning helps
you get exactly where you want to go in
the article a lot of authors are doing
that and we have a lot of other
beginners sort of language guides which
are really helpful and then we also like
to publish articles that are sort of
helping you prepare for interviews I
know you know job searching is stressful
but we have articles like this article
by one of our authors Zubin that is on
system design you know very popular
topic for like big companies and
interviews and again this is just a
super in-depth guide on how to prepare
for a system design interview so there's
a ton more articles I could talk about I
just picked sort of a sampling of some
of the really ones that we're really
excited about so I just want to thank
these authors all of our authors for
sharing these articles with us and you
know it's really meaningful to them when
you share the articles and tweet about
them and get excited about them
bookmark em save them for later you know
they really appreciate it and these
articles just help so many people you
know it's just really it's really
exciting for us to see them and see what
great resources they are so we really
encourage our authors to publish these
kinds of great in-depth articles and and
thank you to everybody reading them for
sharing them they're really helping a
ton of people and that's our mission
here is to help as many people as
possible and just help as many people
learn to code as we can so that's all
from me today I hope you've gotten a
little bit more familiar with news and
how it works
and what we're doing here we're just
really excited to continue sharing these
high-quality articles and lastly I just
want to say if you are interested in
becoming an author on free code camp
news we a lovely style guide I don't
have that pull that Mukesh but yeah
here's our style guide and it kind of
gives you a little bit more about our
editorial philosophy how to write a good
article yeah I mean just read it for
your own purposes also but there are
instructions sort of hidden in there
about how to become an author so do read
through that you'll find a link to a
form to apply to become an author on
news and we would love to see your
application and love
have you contributing your own wonderful
articles to our community and to
everybody so thank you guys so much and
enjoy the rest of the stream thank you
so much heavy and yes Abbey for all of
you who don't know she's edited at this
point probably thousands of articles she
joined us after having she volunteered
and edited hundreds of articles and I
was I mean maybe a thousand and at that
point I was like wow I've been doing
most of the publication oversight myself
so we brought a beyond and she's been
just completely overseeing the
publication and Chris Koishi gawe in
South Korea whom have you mentioned a
couple times he has also been helping
edit articles as well so if you
published an article with freako camp
there's a very good chance that well
well it's it's certain that either me
Abbey or Chris went through your article
line-by-line and and did what we could
to optimize it and make it as clear as
possible for readers the last thing I
want to say is somebody asked Ryan Reed
asked in chat like is news live yet and
is there a difference between the free
code camp medium publication and news
and the answer is back in July of 2019
we moved 100% of our articles like
everything off of medium and over to
this new news platform and because we
wanted to have like full control over
how things were presented and we didn't
want like mediums weird banners and
stuff popping up so we didn't want to
deal with mediums trend toward paywalls
and all that stuff mediums great it's a
good place to publish if you don't
already have like an existing community
like we do but we outgrew medium and
we're thrilled to have needed to be at
this point we're getting significantly
more readership of articles now that
we're on our own instance of ghost which
is the really cool open source MIT
license you feel free to use it
liberally it's it's got the most liberal
license you can get the most permissive
license you can get just like free
cooking up does so if you want to spin
up a blog
mediums are great or I'm sorry ghost is
a great tool for that and we've we've
heavily modified it and I think we're
one of the biggest ghost instances on
the web even though like Apple and a lot
of other places have them I don't think
they're doing you know millions and
millions of readers a month like we are
so we're thrilled that we've like after
we moved off of medium there was a
little bit of a drop just because medium
is such a huge gravitational force in
you know google search and everything
like that but we're now way above where
we were then
so we overcame that and it was thanks to
the many many writers in the community
who continued to write these in-depth
thoughtful insightful articles so I just
want to thank them now the moment a lot
of you have probably been waiting for
beau Karns who by the way runs freako
camps YouTube channel and does a whole
lot of other things there's a lot of
instructional design he was working as a
teacher for about five or six years in
middle school and he's based in Michigan
he and I were talking about YouTube and
he'd been contributing to freako camp
and I was able to convince him to come
on and take over the YouTube channel and
also help with instructional design and
help design curricula and he's been
working on the Python curriculum since
at least five months ago I think like
December 2019 and we've made a whole lot
of progress on it and a lot of this is
ready to go into beta so I'm thrilled to
hand it over to bow Karns to walk us
through some of the big improvements to
the curriculum and the Python
certifications well this first look at
our new Python certifications that we're
adding to the curriculum so currently
our curriculum has six certifications
but we are updating it and now we're
going to have ten certifications so we
you can actually see on the screen right
now that we have a here's our new
certifications and there's there's ten
certifications now so what we did is we
broke up one of the certifications the
the old one called quality assurance and
information security we broke up into
two different certifications in addition
to adding more to adding more content to
each of those certifications and also we
are adding three new certifications that
are all focused on Python so if we go
into the let's go into the scientific
computing with python certification so
there there's three parts of the
certification so we have the the main
part is the certification projects which
you can see open right now and these are
the projects either these are the
required projects you have to do to show
that you understand Python and something
that we are still yet to come out with
practice projects and practice projects
are going to be used to teach people
Python we have a lot done on them but we
don't we're not yet ready to beta test
those practice projects but we are ready
to put into beta test our new type of
challenge which are video challenges so
if we open up this Python for everybody
here you will see a list of new video
challenges so this is the first time
this is a brand new thing for a
curriculum and this is the entire Python
for everybody course created by dr.
Chuck from the University of Michigan
and each Senate we if we broken up into
a lot in four sections so when you go to
the challenge it has an embedded video
right in there so how it works is you
watch the section of the video and then
after you watch this video section
there's a multiple choice question
so each section here has a single
multiple choice question and if you see
on the question we can still we have
sometimes we can embed code on the
question we can beg code on the answers
and so the idea is you watch the video
challenge and then you can answer the
questions to see if you understand the
now we only have a single question for
each video challenge so just because you
can answer this single multiple choice
question doesn't mean you understand
every single element in the video so you
shouldn't just go through the questions
and say oh I know this question so I
don't even have to watch the video you
still should watch each video to get all
the content the question is just a a
small thing to to make sure you
understand everything but you should
still watch the whole video and then if
you get the question right you can go on
to the next challenge until you
eventually go through every single video
challenge and then so for instance if
you go through all the Python for
everybody challenges you will have a
really good understanding of Python now
like I said eventually we're going to
have more of an interactive coding
practice projects to teach Python but
we're still going to continue to have
these video challenges so for each
section for each of the new
certifications we have our practice
projects what no we don't have we have
our certification projects and we also
have the video challenges so let's take
a look at some of those certification
projects these are pretty much
completely done and ready for people to
start using and just so you know
currently all the certification projects
we are you're going to access this on a
on a third-party website so for instance
this one we're gonna access on repli'd
now eventually one thing that we are
working on is adding the ability to
complete all the projects right on
freako can't org without ever going to
any other websites but for now you can
complete the projects on repple it and
so to do the projects you go into that
you click the link on the challenge and
it opens up the repple it and then you
can go into the the readme so if you go
into the readme what you can see the
files on the side this will give you
them all the instructions for the
challenge and what you're supposed to do
so it's going to give you the assignment
all the things you have to do and
so once you kind of understand what
you're supposed to be doing you you can
go in to in this case it's the the
budget dat pie because here we're
creating a budget and this is basically
just an empty file where you're going to
put in your code and you're going to
solve the challenge and then once you
solve the challenge where we're going so
here's what we've just pasted in the
code so this is actually the solution
here and so when you click run it's
going to to run and it's going to also
run all the tests so you can see here
this is the solution code so it passed
all the tests if you go if you go into
the test module that PI we can look at
the test where the tester are stored now
when you're working on the projects
something that can give you a hint of
how to solve the project is to look in
the tests so the tests are available for
anybody to look in into so you can see
exactly what we're looking for and these
are all the tests your your project has
to pass for it to to be able to pass
this this challenge so if you go over to
the the main dot PI file the main dot
fat pie file is the file that runs when
you click the Run button so you can see
in the top Center there's a Run button
when you click the Run button it runs
this main dot pi so you can make updates
to this main dot pi to update what's
gonna like when you're testing it when
you're testing your code you can update
this program and you can see it also
automatically runs the tests so once you
think that you solve the this the
challenge and you have all the tests
passing you can go and click the share
button so if you see in the top right
corner there's a share button and so if
you click that you can copy the link now
one thing I forgot to mention is before
you even start working on the code
you're gonna actually have to create
your own account on repple it and you're
going to have to fork the project so you
can see there's a fork button when you
click the fork button it allows you to
create a copy of the project in your own
account so after you do that
then you can you're able to copy the
link to your project that's right in
your account and once you copy the link
you can go back into the the pre-code
camp curriculum and you can paste in
your solution and then after that you
just click I've completed this challenge
and you can go to the next challenge and
then once you complete every single
project in this certification then you
can claim the certification so currently
we they're just one completed but once
you complete all of them you'll be able
to complain the certification
so all these certifications are going to
be are already to be possibly claimed so
is if you complete all the certification
projects you can claim the certification
when we add the practice projects those
are going to be optional you're not
going to have to do all the practice
projects to claim the certification but
they help and just learning the content
but besides the the scientific computing
with sort of scientific computing with
Python certification we have the data
analysis with python certification and
the machine learning with python
certification so you can see in this
machine learning with python
certification the first two sections
here the tensor flow and how neural
networks work these are all video
challenges so there we have a whole
course on tensorflow
and these are these are all video
challenges and all these will help you
prepare to do the certification
challenges so if we go back over to the
yeah the certification challenge is we
have the machine learning with python
project so these are the certification
projects that once you complete all
these projects you'll be able to claim
the certification now go into that
little go into the cat a dog image
classifier as an example and you will
see that when I go into here this time
instead of opening in revelat it's going
to open in Google collaboratory so
if you click on the first link it's
gonna open the whole project in Google
collaboratory and the reason why we use
Google Laboratory for this one instead
of revelat is because it uses Jupiter
notebook files and these are becoming
pretty industry standard when you're
working on machine learning projects and
so on these Jupiter notebook files it
goes between showing you instructions
and code that you can actually run so if
you follow all the instructions there's
some code that we've given you but
there's some code that you're going to
have to complete yourself to be able to
solve the challenge so if we look at
this code section here that shows um the
train image generator equals none
validation image generator equals none
they're not eventually they're not
supposed to equal nine so part of your
task when you're completing this is to
figure out what these are supposed to
equal so currently we have it set to
equal none but the people going through
this challenge will have to figure out
what they're supposed to equal and once
you've completed all the instructions
and added the code that you're supposed
to add you can go to the very bottom of
this notebook and there's a final sell
of code that when you run it's going to
run all the tests to see if you pass the
tests so if you run the final sell
you'll be able to find up if you pass
the test now one thing that's similar
between this and repair appellate is
that you are going to rebel it is you
have to create your own copy so to
create your own copy you are gonna have
to have a Google account and you go to
file save a copy and drive and you
create your own copy and drive and then
that's where you then fill out all the
code that you need to fill out and once
you've passed the test you can share it
so you click the share button in the top
right corner and then you're going to
get a link that you can share so when
you get the shareable link and then you
just make sure that anybody with the
link can view it you copy the link and
after you copy the link you can go back
over to the free code camp
ulam and you can paste in the link now
like I said eventually you're gonna be
able to do all this right on free Co
camped out or what without having to go
into a separate website like google
collaboratory but until we got to have
that working we're using these
third-party websites and once you have
done all the challenges you can claim
the certifications now one thing I
should add is that so we have the video
challenges that are going to help you
and prepare you to complete these
certification projects but you may have
to do some additional learning on your
own so these video challenges are going
to teach you a lot of what you need to
know but some of the what you need to
know to complete these certifications
these certification projects is going to
involve doing some extra research and
extra learning on other websites and
that kind of simulates what it's going
to be like when you have a job or you
have to kind of learn to to learn how to
learn and figure out how to get the the
Ries how to get the knowledge you need
to complete different projects so that's
what you would have to do in a in a real
world situation and that's what you'll
have to do on videos and once we release
the practice projects they'll probably
they'll probably a little less you'll
have to go to other websites for but
this is pretty much an overview of our
the new curriculum that we're going to
be rolling out for a beta testing very
very soon so it's going very very soon
you're gonna be able to go and see all
this stuff on the the beta site for free
code camp org and you'll be able to
start trying out all this on your own so
that's all I have to say about this I
guess a little go back to Quincy and see
if Quincy has anything else he wants to
add about it hey thank you so much Bo
for giving us that excellent overview of
the new Python certifications and also
thank you for all the time and energy
you put into developing these over the
past five months so we are still working
on finalizing
exactly what the tests look like in the
projects and getting all that done but
as Bo said we're hoping to get this live
this month like May so that you all can
start diving through and getting the
earning these certifications the general
flow oh and by the way I'm gonna go
ahead and put out a call for any
questions you all have that you'd like
to ask about just go ahead and ask in
chat again if you're not if you haven't
joined yet there's a join button cost
like five dollars a month or I'm not
sure how many rupees but it's scaled to
your currency and it'll be less
expensive in certain places
no there's but it helps us a lot and
that way ask questions and also chat on
other strange
so what we're planning to do is just
roll out the updated the expanded
curriculum in stages
our first step as both said is to get
these four new certifications live then
our next step will be to try to get it
to where all these projects including
the projects currently people are doing
on my code pin and J's been in place
like that we're gonna get it to where
you can complete all the projects right
on free coconut org we're we're working
toward that that's challenging it's
challenging to run Python in a browser
it's challenging to have full-stack
software development done client-side
without a you know dramatically
exploding our server bill and that's one
of the reasons we've been a little bit
slower to do that and that's why we
still encourage people to use glitch and
a lot of these other services to build
the projects and host the projects and
then just link to them in the free code
camp in the curriculum where you you
submit the link to the project that you
built a lot of that is also just because
we're a small team and we don't have the
resources to directly moderate every
single piece of you know every single
project and if you want to read a little
bit more about how hard it is to
successfully moderate you know a site
where anybody can just create anything
read the the
who created J has been created this
great article about the hell that is
running J has been is an amazing story
I'll try to find a link for it but there
are a number of reasons why what we're
doing is very difficult I just want to
reassure you all we're doing everything
we can we're working as fast as we can
but a lot of these are genuinely hard
problems that we're working on and of
course we're working with very limited
resources as we're guest pointed out
Wikipedia's budget is about 200 times
greater than free coke camps even though
freako camp is rapidly yeah I mean we're
not anywhere near the amount of traffic
and and and number of people that are
using pre Coe camp as we're using
Wikipedia but we're definitely more than
you know one two hundredth of the way so
anything you all can give us helps a lot
helps us pay for servers it helps us
enlist you know seasoned teachers like
bo Karns to help design these projects
and and help do other instructional
design so as both said we're gonna start
off with these video challenges these
are excellent video courses that are
coming from campus to YouTube channel
where we have full-length courses such
as the one we just published yesterday
on PI torch which is a really important
machine learning library we we have tons
of full-length courses over there that
you can use you are going to want to be
googling around you're gonna want to be
supplementing everything you learn on
free code camp as Bo said there is no
one-stop shop any website that says all
you need is right here well I can tell
you there's no such site because free
cooking it probably has dramatically
more instructional content than any
other programming related site and yet
I'm telling you as the person who
charged a free cooking we're just
scratching the surface technology is an
ocean
we're having a open-ended question and
being able to ask on the forum or just
Google around and find some blog article
or some course video on YouTube and use
that to fill in the gaps in your own
knowledge we're gonna do our best to
explain everything within free code camp
but realistically there's just so much
to teach and there's so much to learn
that you are going to want to get really
good at googling things and really good
at coming up with questions and asking
them on the forum so we have some
questions from the audience and just
real quick like the general we don't use
deadlines a lot of people ask me wins
this coming out when's that coming out
we don't do deadlines within freako camp
because we want to get things good
enough before we ship them so sorry
somebody said something in chat and I
was just wasn't sure so we are going to
we're gonna continue to just ship things
as we feel they're ready there's a great
quote from Shigeru Miyamoto the famous
designer of Zelda Mario all these famous
franchises of video games and he said a
rushed game is forever bad a delayed
game he's eventually good and that's how
I feel I feel that it's much better for
us to do things right than to just rush
them at the door and send tons of people
to a unfinished experience so what we're
trying to do is we're using Google's
collaboratory we're using replicas we're
using a glitch so phase one of course
get these Python certifications live
with the video challenges phase two is
going to be us
to where you can go through the entire
curriculum right on freako camp without
having to use these external services
phase three is going to be us creating
the practice projects for the Python
curriculum and for eventually for the
existing the first six certifications so
all that will probably happen in 2020
but I'm not gonna promise anything
because again it'll be done when it's
done please give us the the patience
that we're gonna work as fast as we can
one thing I want to emphasize to
everybody watching this is you don't
have to wait for any of this everything
we're doing like all the existing
certifications will continue to exist we
don't destroy content we don't destroy
certifications once they're live we'll
always support them and we've done that
like we had the old curriculum the old
certifications those are still alive
everybody who's claimed those
certification still has those
certifications the links are still valid
we don't want it's it's like playing a
you know a game of go you put you put
the piece on the board and the piece
stays on the board right and the rest of
the game is kind of shaped going forward
by that piece and that's how freako
campus we want to put things down and we
want to expand from there so the
curriculum is linear you can work
through the entire thing from top to
[Laughter]
polity experience certification is being
split into two certifications but the
projects associated with those are still
in the curriculum
it's just that two of the projects from
the Information Security Quality
Assurance are being moved from the
Quality Assurance to the information
security certification and the
information security certification is
being included to include a lot of linux
and python as well so we're very excited
about those updates as well and and we
think these are sound from a pedagogical
standpoint we think this makes more
sense to employers who are looking at
your resume or your CV and trying to
decide how to make sense of these
certifications you've earned so
eventually we will have ten
certifications and you'll be able to go
through all those but right now if
you're working through the first six
certification
keep going nothing is going to change
that is substantial
yes we're replacing the lessons with
practice projects later in 2020 probably
but that the lessons are all optional
you just have to complete the projects
in order to earn the certifications and
the projects for those first six
certifications are not going to change
dramatically all right let's jump to
questions so first of all I just want to
let's see
people people ask I'm new to computer
program and I want to know where to
start what I would recommend is just
work through the free cooking curriculum
from start to finish top to bottom that
has baked into it all of the knowledge
all the wisdom we have and another thing
you could do is if you google like
coronavirus Academy I just put together
an article somebody can probably share
it in chat but it's a comprehensive
article saying what you know courses and
what in addition to the free cooking
curriculum that you could use to kind of
learn as much as possible during this
lockdown period and during this period
of social distancing Zoli asks what do
you think is the popularity of Python as
a web development framework over
JavaScript I am someone who I want to
learn Python but I don't I don't want to
have to learn JavaScript as well okay
well I'll go ahead answer that for you
so Lee and I am gonna give some of these
over to a b-bow and in murugesh but for
this question I'll just say javascript
is absolutely something everybody should
learn it's the lingua franca of the web
I think it's a much better place to
start than Python Python is a good
second language javascript is the best
first language you can absolutely wrap I
thought I learned Python first but if I
could go back in time especially in 2020
where JavaScript has progressed so much
I would definitely learn JavaScript
first so if you look at our curriculum
we teach JavaScript comprehensively you
spend a whole lot of time with
JavaScript before you even get to Python
and that's by design they're both high
level scripting languages everything you
can do with Python you can do with
JavaScript Python has better libraries
for certain things
then javascript does javascript has
better libraries for certain things than
python does you ideally want to know
both but if you could only learn one
you'd want to learn JavaScript so I
definitely recommend that you do learn
JavaScript and I'd say it's unavoidable
if you want to be a developer in 2020
you're gonna have to learn JavaScript it
would be like trying to be a business
person and not have to learn English or
something in 2020 I just don't think
it's it's very viable so we've got some
other questions let's see okay I think
does anybody else have any questions I
think we've answered all the ones that I
see in the chat so I'll give you all a
moment to ask the questions but what I
want to do right now is I want to talk a
little bit about flooring pop who is
about to take over the stream this guy's
a legend if you haven't heard of him he
did the 100 days of code challenge boom
like no big deal right 100 days of code
by the way
hashtag 100 days ago check it out if
you're new to coding it's a great way to
stay motivated while you learn after 100
days of code he did this challenge
called 100 projects in 100 days amazing
look at the projects he built they are
awesome and it shows his genuine breadth
of creativity and a lot of other cool
things he's done like there's so many
really cool projects many of which we're
hoping to eventually convert into take
home projects in the interview
preparation section or eco camp then
flooring pop went on his on I think it
was on his YouTube and he worked through
the entire free cocaine curriculum from
start to finish building like doing all
the lessons and building all the
projects and that he did the entire
thing in 28 days now keep in mind he's
he's a professional developer he's been
working as a developer for a while he
had already learned most of that stuff
so he
is not a typical person like a typical
person is not going to be able to just
sit down and work through a frico camp
in 28 days as far as I can tell that's
the world record but the fact that he
streamed it is really freaking cool and
so he's been streaming a ton and now
today after this video ends and we're
handing it over to him on the same
stream you don't have to go anywhere you
just stay here and he is going to work
through the the first 100 project Euler
problems it's it's called project Euler
100 hashtag project Euler 100 challenge
so if he if he's able to complete the
entire thing I think he'll be the first
person to complete it formally since we
started the prowl many people probably
tens of thousands of people at this
point over the last 20 years have
completely the first 100 challenges but
they are very challenging I mean these
are this is when you hear of competitive
programming where people get like a you
know a vague assignment like here's a
data set figure out how to do turn this
into this you know things like that
that's what project Euler is you use all
your algorithm or your data structure or
your system design or your mathematical
knowledge to bring that all to force and
you spend a lot of time looking things
up and if you watch him stream this
you're gonna probably find that he
spends a lot of times scratching his
head and a lot of time looking things up
because that's what real programmers do
people don't just sit down and bash out
like a perfect program like you see in
the movies in real life there's a lot of
thinking so we're gonna get to watch a
lot of that real time on this channel so
there are a few more questions I just
want to make sure that I answer them all
Quincy there's one which is has been
asked quite a few times is what is the
prerequisite to start learning Python
which is you know like it's a very good
question I think Bo if you want to take
that yeah go ahead Bo yeah so if you
especially if you're gonna be using our
new curriculum and using the video
challenges we have the Python for
everybody video challenges and there is
absolutely no
requisites to start going through that
it's taught in a way that will it's
geared toward people that are completely
brand new to programming I mean it's
always helpful I mean anytime you know
another programming language is helpful
but you can go through the Python for
everybody video challenges on this new
beta curriculum with absolutely no
prerequisites excellent answer bow so
again there are no prerequisites for
learning Python you can just grab Python
for everybody the the free code camp
YouTube video or you can just use the
free cocaine curriculums new we like
broke it down and we add a comprehensive
comprehension check questions so if we
didn't show regattas screen real quick
and by the way I want to thank Matthew
Potter who's been engineering this
entire thing he also did lockdown comp
he's in the control room here so
somebody asked our people hiring free
code camp grads it's a great question so
I am thrilled to announce this is an
announcement it's right on our landing
page but but if you look we I've gone
through and analyzed a lot of the people
in the free code camp Alumni Association
which has about 300,000 followers but it
has I think 55 ish thousand people who
claim certifications here and who've
taken the time to list their
certifications on their on their
LinkedIn profile so I've gone through
and analyzed these and from these there
are at least 40,000 people who've gotten
their first developer job after
completing at least part of frigo camp
40,000 people so just keep that in mind
like that's that's like as many alumni
as a university might crank out over the
course of you know 50 years or something
and we've done it now I'm not comparing
pre-cooking to go university because
they're completely different things but
I'm just trying to drive home the scale
of the number of people who have used
freako camp as a tool to prepare for the
job application process and to get
through coding in
and all that we have an entire section
of the the freako camp of learn it
British if you want to pull that up
it's called interview prep and we have
hundreds of algorithm and data structure
related challenges that you can go
through those are precisely the kinds of
things that if you apply for a job at
like Amazon or Microsoft you're gonna
see those kinds of those kinds of
questions come up and we also have a lot
of additional projects you can build for
practice and things like that and we've
got most of rosetta codes major projects
rosetta code is another big open source
creative commons-licensed project like
project oiler and we also have just a
ton of data structure type things that
our community is built in if you have
ideas for projects you'd like to
contribute to this or algorithm
challenges you'd like to contribute to
this this is something we're hoping to
dramatically grow over the next year we
could go from thousands of hours worth
of algorithm challenges to tens of
thousands of hours worth like the idea
is you should never run out of
programming practice on freako camp
you can always expand your skills a
little bit further all right I don't see
any other big questions in the chat
people asking about switching from Java
to a full stack role if you are learning
if you've already been working as a
developer using java using net using
some of the other tools that are still
used widely especially at large
corporations it shouldn't be too hard to
learn JavaScript or Python these are
most new projects created are created
using you know JavaScript ecosystem
tools like if you go if you look at like
LinkedIn or Walmart or Netflix these are
all websites that heavily use nodejs
and yes some of them will be using even
newer tools like rust or like golang
things like that and at certain levels
of performance like I think we
I think he's like Haskell or Erlanger
Celine so there are real world
implementations of all these different
languages but if you learn nodejs really
comprehensively that will open you up to
the maximum number of potential jobs and
one thing I always emphasize is don't
try to specialize before you get the job
just be a really strong generalist then
apply for jobs and then specialize once
you're on the job and an employer is
like hey I want you to work on this
project or this project you work on 10
DevOps related projects and suddenly you
have a DevOps skill set that you learned
on somebody else's dollar in the field
right you don't sit at home and say I'm
gonna become a DevOps and just crank
through a bunch of Linux tutorials and
expect to go out and get like a really
advanced DevOps type career generally
it's you get in as a more general
developer role and then you progress
from there or you transition within your
current company if you're fortunate
enough to still have a job in this
massive recession you just talk to
people in your engineering department
and you gradually do more and more work
there and next thing you know you're in
the developer bullpen or what will
hopefully become the developer office
suite uh-huh post pandemic and you are
able to work for that company in that
capacity as well so I just want to thank
everybody for tuning in I want to thank
everybody who became a member or who did
super test during this we are going to
have a whole lot of live streams that's
one of the final big announcements and
we're gonna go ahead and hand it over to
floor and pop who is gonna start
streaming his amazing attempt at project
weather 100 so stay tuned for that I
will still be in chat also answer
questions and again just be sure to
check the description of the chat we've
got a whole lot of notes from this if if
you want and I just want to thank you
all for being a part of the free code
camp community for making use of these
learning resources that so many teachers
around the world are contributing to
free code camp when I encourage you all
to
subscribe to the YouTube channel if
you're not already subscribed and tell
your friends there and one of the
biggest ways you can help just to tell
your friends if you have friends who are
out of the job
during this massive global recession if
you have friends who are in school who
are like I don't know if I want to spend
a whole bunch of money to go to
university next year if it's just gonna
be a bunch of zoom calls and Google
Hangouts and stuff like that be sure to
tell them about free cocaine because it
may provoke hamp is an alternative to
university but certainly if you're
looking to take like a gap here this
could be a really productive way to use
that time while you're hanging out with
your family or while you're working on
different things that you do at home we
don't know when social distancing is
going to end in certain countries like
the government may open up the cut the
open up the economy but maybe a lot of
smart people will just stay home because
they don't want to get this horrible
disease that's going around so whatever
happens we're gonna be here to help you
make the most of your time and your
energy and we're going to try our best
to make sure that you keep moving
forward with your skills and with your
career thank you again